[Applause]
I never had a standing ovation Wi-Fi you
can do whatever you want anything you
want to refine the great show this guy
created this guy it's this show this
show I mean every shot you saw there I
came through this gentleman's mind
through his eye through his sensibility
to his generosity you know he put
together an incredible team he's
incredibly gifted artist but the message
of kindness comes from his heart and
also the creation of a female doctor
comes really from the creation of a
female master
plays so beautifully by Michelle who has
delivered a multi-layered hilarious
sinister and fabulous performance for
which I'm deeply grateful so Jodi the
idea of a Time Lord being both many
female came from Steve peril has been an
absolutely magnificent new contribution
to the show she stepped into this is
this juggernaut that we have and brought
us a real living character in Bill Potts
who had her feet on the ground and her
heart and a star which is where we all
want to be right matt has come along and
delivered a fabulous creation a whole
brand new thing an alien being who is a
sidekick who's a little bit scary a
little bit funny and a huge contribution
to the show and has come into it with a
generosity of spirit and kindness
because this is a man who is immensely
famous immensely talented and he stepped
up to the plate in our show
[Applause]
with humility and grace and made season
10 one of the most special seasons ever
mark what can I say about mark is a
great great friend a great lover and
supporter of doctor and all that sounds
a bit odd that doctor who needs lovers
and supporters but the show hasn't
always enjoyed the success that it
enjoys at the moment it's not always
been the most popular show to hang your
your coat on mark has always been there
for the show he's written some of the
most fabulous episodes and I'm so
thrilled that he's finally been able to
appear in the show and I was able to act
with him so thank you very much Oh God I
just did a big speech though I didn't
really like
you